we're NFL great now working for CBS
boomer joins us good morning boomer
hey good morning damn thanks for having
me on I hope you don't get me in trouble
I would how could I get you in trouble
you Savin off we're not supposed to be
cross pollinating like this CBS you see
you do that I do this you stay in your
lane I stay in mind but you know your
friends this morning we'll all work for
the same person one day boomer I pick
you all right help me with the Carson
Wentz knee injury and and what this does
to a team as let's say assume he's out
is Philadelphia still the best team in
the NFC you know I don't think so I
think Nick Foles is sure enough good
enough back up the more you see the less
you like so backup quarterbacks are
insurance policies and hopefully their
short-term insurance policies
unfortunately for the Philadelphia
Eagles assuming what we all think is
going to be announced at noon by
Peterson their head coach Nick Foles is
going to be the long-term answer or at
least for this season and into the
playoffs he's a client he's a fine
quarterback he had a good season back in
Philadelphia a few years back he does
not turn the football over but what
carson ones does in the football field
is hard to recreate he does a lot other
things that Andrew Luck did for the
Indianapolis Colts when they went to the
AFC Championship game in deflategate so
you're losing a premier player you're
losing the heart and soul of your
football team and he plays like it as a
matter of fact during the game yesterday
I actually tweeted out if you want to
watch how an NFL quarterback competes on
the daily basis just watch course and
once and unfortunately he competed a
little bit too hard and then let himself
to injury so it's a devastating injury
nonetheless and it really strikes to the
heart of the Philadelphia Eagles but
boomer can he be too competitive because
we saw that with Andrew Luck is there is
there that kind of light that goes on
that says I got to pick my spots Cam
Newton's doing this better than he used
to but like once is not afraid to take
you on and neither is Andrew Luck
sitting on the sidelines and that's the
thing you know Eli Manning is like Gumby
he never gets hurt
Tom Brady for some reason never gets
hurt even though he'd been really
ever takes a direct shot but neither of
those guys run like luck and went and of
course that came dude I think what Cam
Newton's doing is ridiculous because
there are times where they just call
plays and they say you take the ball in
between the tackles now a six foot five
250 pounds of Rolling Thunder I guess
you can do that at that size but even he
missed a significant portion of seasons
a few years ago so I would always say
this you know and you're talking to a
guy that only really had to deal with
injuries in terms of concussions and
ankles I never had any surgeries never
broke any bones and never missed a long
period of time due to injuries like what
Carson is suffering from the NFL
football field is a very very dangerous
place especially when you are a
quarterback and you're out in the open
and I understand exactly what course it
was doing yesterday and I understand
what Andrew Luck brought to the post
calls but at the end of the day you want
these guys on the field we need them as
broadcasters you know we need them as
our companies want those guys on the
field like we saw last night on NBC with
Ben Roethlisberger so I'm sick over it I
feel bad about it and certainly
hopefully he'll learn a very valuable
lesson moving forward
he's boomer esiason the NFL on CBS
analyst WFAN talk show host in the
morning if so Philadelphia is not your
favorite if you were going to rank your
teams in the NFC right now best team is
well even though they didn't play great
yesterday they still were in that game
and they had a chance to win the game
late in the game and even though it is
Case Keenum
I still think Case Keenum has proven a
lot of people wrong they have a
tremendous defense and they are going to
be very difficult to beat at home you
know if they can get the number one seed
even if they don't get the number one
seed and they have to go on the road in
an NFC Championship game and play in
Philadelphia because the loss of course
and once it's so significant I believe
that the game that they can win so I
think right now they have to be the
odds-on favorite the other thing not the
Shakers thick-ass really is the fact
that we have Atlanta now and in the 6e
and the problem with the NFC South is
you noticed and they all play within
that division in the last two weeks it's
the only division in football that
actually has this or all the games
all eight games of the season are within
the division so there's a lot that can
change from where we said today third
best team in the AFC is that's a really
good question I would say the Chargers
the Chargers are flying right now I'm
assuming that they're going to go into
Kansas City and beat the Chiefs and
Arrowhead when you look at their defense
and the way that Phillip Rivers has been
playing the last three to four weeks and
you realize that early in the season
that they did not lose games because
their offense and defense they lost
games because of their kicking game you
realize just how good they really are so
you know I think I think that the
Chargers are flying they're coming and
they're gonna be tough to spot and stop
they've won 44 in a row right now and
their confidence is this season anyway
is their all-time high I know of doing
the mornings in New York City
you being a Mets fan and the Yankees
just pulled off this great deal getting
in Carlos Stanton how does this not work
out for the Yankees wow that's a really
good question you know they have a new
new manager who I'm sure has got
baseball in his blood Aaron Boone and
the Boone family no more baseball than I
could ever know but what Aaron Boone is
about ready to get himself into is not
just managing in between you know the
foul lines on a daily basis but it's
managing personalities people and I
thought Georgia already did an
unbelievable job last year and I'm not
even a Yankee fan I just sit here and I
watch in amazement
you know how the Yankees do business I'm
actually as a met fan just not shocked
by anything that happens and the way
that our general manager reacts to it
that we have Brandon Nemo in right field
so we weren't really interested in Junko
but tell us all you need know I would
just say Aaron Boone's gonna have his
hands full because he's got a lot of a
tie personalities a lot of great players
in one dugout and managing the Yankees
is more than just managing the game it's
managing personalities media fans
expectations front office meddling and
certainly now with Brian Cashman getting
a five-year twenty five million dollar
deal as a general manager of the Yankees
we really know who's running that place
over there with Ben McAdoo just not
built to be in New York as a head coach
or just not built to be a head coach you
know Dan I always tell fans that the
most important
person that an organization can hire is
its head coach its manager no matter
what are the big four sports you have
here in New York you have to have
somebody that when they are
communicating to the fanbase comes off
as if they know what they're doing I
don't know what happened to Ben McAdoo
you know during the offseason last year
when they hired him he had the Dutch boy
you know haircut he looked like a kid
from Pennsylvania who just ascended to a
job that he certainly deserved but then
all of a sudden something happened in
the off season where he came back with
the slicked back hair and he tried to be
Bill Belichick and you know couple
players you know skipped out on him he
had a suspend some players Eli Apple was
giving inside information to ESPN and
you had basically a kind of just a
sequence of events that just made him
look bad and I thought it was a mercy
firing to be honest with you because
could you imagine if you were standing
on the sideline yesterday with that
performance against the Cowboys in his
home stadium no so he was he was just
not a fit for New York so that's why
whoever they hire better be of stature
better be of a good communication guy
and somebody when he stands in front of
the fans and the players it's gonna
elicit some sort of credibility if
you're Eli do you want to stay I
wouldn't I know that he loves the Giants
I know that he loves plan for the
Maryland dish family he's often said
that I don't necessarily know that
Jacksonville will be looking for a new
quarterback given the fact that Blake
bortles has had his two best games
back-to-back career but I was thinking
you know a few weeks ago that if he
could somehow get himself to
Jacksonville to reunite with Tom
Coughlin with that football team that
may be all they need but saying all of
that things happen in the NFL and they
change pretty quickly and that's why
Blake bortles performance the last two
games you know you got to open your eyes
now if this kids going to play like that
Jacksonville maybe that third or fourth
best team in the league that can go on
the road with that defense and shut down
an opposing quarterback like they did
about five or six weeks ago in
Pittsburgh
good stuff boomer I don't think you got
yourself in trouble I appreciate you
know let me watch at least okay thank
you boomer good to talk to you boomer
esiason NFL on CBS analyst WFAN talk
show host yeah
get anybody in trouble here not nothing
wrong with you no cross-pollinating CBS
NBC well interview yeah we get along
mothership Fox yeah you just throw it in
the blender
spit it out each morning for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]